he said that there's no justice in
Romania no justice in Romania
unfortunately he's saying that Romania
is corrupt which is so fascinating to me
because that's actually one of the main
reasons why he moved to Romania because
he felt that it was the least corrupt of
all the other countries including the
United Kingdom America so the fact that
Romania is now sort of like turning on
him is really interesting does this
potentially mean that the Matrix is
everywhere and it doesn't matter how
many grids you're on or the systems in
those different countries they're all
basically one and they're all out to get
you I don't know I wonder why he didn't
just stay in Dubai because it seemed
like Dubai was okay